here in this video we shall list down
the 20 biggest american movie monsters
which means no japanese kaiju or
others from other countries there are
pretty big ones on this list and many
are familiar
but there are also very new entries so
let's dive into this list
and let's do this thing number 20 lizzy
the smallest one on this list is the
giant lizzy which comes from the movie
rampage
lizzie maintains the basic shape of a
crocodile but in addition to her
gigantic size
lizzie has developed two huge dust from
each side of her head
and below the jaws as well a pair of
frills countless large spikes on her
back
and a spike club on her tail as well as
gecko-like feet
and she was said to be over 200 feet
long
number 19 zilla coming next is the
american version of godzilla which was
not
taken with warmness by the japanese
audience and so it became just zilla
an american creation unlike the
mainstream godzilla which is erect in
posture
and has dorsal plates that resemble
maple leaves zilla is hunched like a
dinosaur and has a square jaw like
arnold schwarzenegger
moreover the body shape limbs and evil
dolls or plates are
well unique and this monster was 200
feet tall and three times as long
number 18 behemoth
this one is from the horror sci-fi movie
the midst of stephen king
and it was seen briefly but nonetheless
it was breathtaking
the behemoth has six double jointed legs
each of them hundreds of feet tall
hundreds of multiple jointed appendages
on its underside and tentacles above its
head
the behemoth size is estimated at over
240 feet
larger than anything that has ever lived
on earth in that franchise
and due to its immense size it was not
hostile as nothing natural could harm it
number 17 the colossal monster
[Music]
an odd addition to the list is anne
hathaway's kaiju called
colossal which was funny and was also an
avatar of the character that appears
half a while away whenever she steps on
a magical sandbox
it is a gigantic semi-humanoid reptilian
creature with thick scaly brown skin
it has a short stumpy tail elephant-like
feet and humanoid hands
the creature's head is a dawn with a
crests with smaller horns jutting out
it was easily 250 to 300 feet tall or 25
stories in height
number 16 the mutos
[Music]
alright so even though they are in the
same movie as godzilla which is a
japanese creation the mutos are uniquely
american in design and origin
there are four types of murals the
smallest was the male one
which was 200 feet tall then there was
the female and the queen muto which were
roughly 300 feet tall
and lastly there was demuter prime which
was bigger at more than 300 feet tall
but maybe less than 350.
number 15 king kong
the giant ape the first giant monster of
the movie screens comes on the 15th spot
with the monsterverse incarnation of it
king kong has had many adaptations and
incarnations
from the first one in 1933 which was
roughly 20 feet tall to the japanese
king kong vs godzilla
in which he stood 148 feet in height in
the newest monster verse movie godzilla
vs kong
the big ape got another upgrade in size
and was now 337 feet tall
number 14 monster versus titans on this
next entry we decided to club in
all the titans of the monster verse as
it will make room for other bigger
monsters as well on this list
of course there were smaller titans and
sub titans
but the biggest switch were unique
designs of the most verse which makes
them american creations
and not kaijus of japan were the
behemoth sila
methuselah and others which comes in the
range of anywhere between 300 to 400
feet in height
number 30 in the kraken
this one comes from the clash of the
titans remake and it's called the kraken
it is a
big monster with tentacles that are
large enough to be able to pull entire
ships underwater and destroy cities with
relative ease
the creature looks like a humanoid
crustacean in design
in addition to tentacles the creature
was armed with a gaping mouth
full of many sharp teeth and the
creature's many tentacles afforded at
great speed and swimming
this monster was easily over 400 feet
tall
number 12 the mega kaiju
coming in from the pacific rim universe
with many monsters in it we have decided
to just put in a couple
entries of these kaiju's and this one is
the mega kaiju from the second movie
uprising
this monster for monster was 500 feet
tall as per the official statistics
and was an amalgamation of three other
kaijus that were combined to defeat
humanity
and its army of jaegers it had two tales
and armored characters then
eyes dusk and a range of deadly features
number 11 cthulhu although debatable in
size cthulhu from the movie underwater
is massive and deserves the 11th spot
he is as large as a mountain has
grotesque vaguely humanoid upper body
and a head with an octopus like
characteristics he has an elongated
scalp with four eyes
a chin covered with a beard of tentacles
and a jaw that displays many layers of
fangs and teeth
and a lower jaw that appears to split in
two he has bone-like wings and appears
to be over 500 feet long
number 10 slathered
[Music]
and yet another one from the pacific rim
universe this one is from the first
movie and although there is a debate on
which is bigger
official statistics show saturn bigger
than a mega kaiju
the largest and strongest of all the
known kaiju slan is unrivaled by any of
its brethren in battle
it has a hammer-like head a tail that
branches off into three prehensile
smaller ones
and four legs and he was 596 feet tall
when standing upright
number nine the mind flayer not really
from the movies but from a show called
stranger things
the mind flayer is said to be 50 stories
tall or 600 feet in height
his body appears to be entirely composed
of minuscule particles giving him a
misty appearance
akin to that of a shadow it is unknown
if the mind flay is entirely made of
smoke or if there
is any physical anatomy to the creature
the creature
has multiple limbs some of which branch
into several small appendages number
eight
alaite a very new entry to the cinematic
universe and this is from the mcu show
loki
alaite is the name of a giant monster at
the end of time
it appears to be a smoke monster much
like the mind player
and can also create limbs from its
gaseous body it has an amorphous shape
but a skull like a face like that of a
canine skull and fires inside its mouth
and eyes
it was hard to determine the size but
since it was able to match
asgard's palace so it must be between
one thousand and one thousand five
hundred feet tall
number seven chronos this next one is
from the movie wrath of the titans and
it is as big as a volcanic mountain and
the very heart of ancient greek
mythology
cronus is considered as usual as an evil
god and a bad parent
he was locked in a place called tartarus
for thousands of years and once he broke
out
we saw him as a volcanic entity whose
body was composed of rock and lava
he was stated to be 500 meters or 1 640
feet tall
number six dormammu yet another one from
the mcu
this monster is an interdimensional
entity called domamu which was seen in
the movie doctor strange
it was kind of hard to determine your
mama's size since
his entire body wasn't seen but by
extrapolating a humanoid design
with the face that appeared in the movie
killing dr strange this monster from the
dark dimension would have been between
a thousand to two thousand feet tall
number five the exaggerth finally an
entry from star wars and it takes the
fifth spot on this list of the twenty
american monsters
space locks or exogords reach full
maturity at 10 meters
and reproduce by splitting into two
smaller separate bodies
and if the space lock was incapable of
this process its growth continues
uninterrupted
potentially reaching lengths of 900
meters or 3000 feet long
the species existed for billions of
years
as the one seen in star wars was at
least a billion years old itself
number 4 certa yet again from the mcu
this giant fire demon was the antagonist
of the movie thor ragnarok
and was stole as a mountain in the final
scenes it was maybe a kilometer tall or
3200 feet in height
serta was one of the most powerful
beings in the cosmos capable even in his
weakened state
of nearly overpowering thor and after
being resurrected by the eternal flame
certain powers were immeasurably
increased as he was finally able to
bring ragnarok to asgard
and destroy the entire place number
three
parallax so if we have a couple from the
marvel universe of course
one will come from the dc universe and
this is parallax of the movie green
lantern
this amorphous entity was the embodiment
of fear in the universe
and when it was released from its prison
parallax went on to consume worlds
and in the process increasing in size up
to a point where it was between two to
three kilometers in size
when it reached earth or between seven
thousand to ten thousand feet
across number two the summer vermont
another star wars mastered this giant
technical beast
the space monster is the castle run
creature also known as the summer
vermont
it was seen in solo a star wars story
and it takes the second spot
this creature had a jellyfish-like body
and was also similar to squids and
octopus its long tentacles made it one
of the biggest in the star wars universe
at around 7 432 meters or 24 000 feet
long
it was however killed when it was sucked
down the black hole
and number one the cloverfield monster
and finally the number one spot goes to
none other than the cloverfield paradox
movie monster or simply known as clover
it first appeared in the first
glovefield movie as a baby
but still it was 300 feet tall and in
the end scenes of the third movie it was
seen towering over the clouds
which would put it anywhere between five
to eight kilometers tall
or sixteen thousand to twenty four
thousand feet in height
cementing him on the number one spot of
the biggest american movie monsters
and so with that we come to the end of
the video of the biggest american movie
monsters so do click that like button
for support
and subscribe if you haven't do check
out our other videos as well
and finally smash that bell button like
the hot smashes thing
puny button for regular updates on new
monster videos right here on minecube
till the next one take care fam